[Música]
olá crianças tenho 7.9 como diria minha
neta barbie isso lançam anos então tenho
79 há muito pouco tempo descobri que não
tenho mais 33
fiquei neles muitos e muitos anos
isso quer dizer que hoje me sinto com 50
mais ou menos crianças é semana passada
houve algo muito lindo noticiário que
dizia que a itália só consideraria como
idosos pessoas acima de 75 anos e que a
mente das pessoas de 70 anos hoje é
igual à mente de pessoas de 50 anos de
antigamente
olha o lucro isso também quer dizer que
nós estamos vivendo mais
nós podemos chegar aos 90 inteira o
nariz mas nós não estamos sabendo o que
fazer com o tempo esse presente
maravilhoso que nos foi dada tanto tempo
a mais de vida
nós pegamos esse presentinho colocamos
lá no fundo do nosso armário e nos
tornamos invisíveis invisíveis como
nossas mães é dada a minha pelo menos
ela
depois de criarem seus filhos elas não
te aposentavam se aposentavam delas
mesmas
há dois anos eu me aposentei de uma
firma onde trabalhei durante 45 anos
nos primeiro ano eu fiz muita terapia
[Música]
muito pilates muitos cursos
fiz tudo que eu não tinha tempo de fazer
antes eu fiz mas eu estava vazia e eu
tava sem tesão em um belo dia me ligaram
convidando pra ver café 50 mais vamos lá
cheguei um monte de menininhas assim
como eu 60 70 80 90 e os meninos também
a palestrante disse por favor hoje nós
temos gente não fala que na reunião
gostaria que eles levantassem dissessem
seu nome o que para o que estão fazendo
e se tem algum projeto
eu levantei também era umas 8
aquele projeto projeto aquilo não me
saía às meninas falando ninguém falava
em projeto chegou a minha vez pois não
eu sou helena acha durante 50 anos eu
fiz estilo e agora e apareça
o menino disse a senhora tem algum
projeto dona helena
sim coleção lingerie 60 mais
foi o até pra mim
fomos tomar os famoso café 50 mais um
grupo de menininha se dirigiu a mim diz
ele né assim muito prazer é nós
gostaríamos de saber aonde que a gente
pode comprar essas peças 60 mais enfim
loja só tem fábrica é não mas logo vocês
vão encontrar nas lojas
eu vou comunicar ao café 50 mais e aí
vocês vão saber onde procurar sair de lá
projetos ainda o fogo da cabeça
não dormi até a noite de manhã cedo e
seu agente take a pronta na cabeça mais
faltava quem produzisse passei a mão o
telefone liguei para uma amiga que tem
uma das maiores fábricas de lingerie do
brasil disse me que eu sei que você não
está aqui está viajando mas escuta aí eu
tô com a uma coleção fantástica lingerie
60 mais topo tô com você
tamo junto e eu falei que ia ficar
quieta eu estou pagando a ligação
eu estou gastando eu quero continuar e
tem mais eu euzinha quero ser a cara
dessa coleção eu quero fazer as fotos do
catálogo quero desfilar e quero todas as
minhas ruguinhas que tem o direito sem
photoshop
ok pode começar na lateral
a loucura muito pouco tempo e tinha
menos que três meses
a coleção geral da eles vão sair agora e
muito menos dois meses dois se pouco e
imagina que a minha coleção 60 mas não
ia sair junto e eu não ia sair da
invisibilidade necas de pitibiriba as
mãos à obra arregacei e vão embora mas
eu tinha um grande grande problema
meu maior como é que eu ia passar aquela
ideia como é que eu ia passar
a grande mensagem
qual era a grande mensagem inspirar
milhões de mulheres a sair da
invisibilidade da pesca daquela coleção
teria que estar falando escuta você tá
aqui você pode você tem todos os
direitos você tenham mais uma vida a ser
vivida e esta vida é linda e que pode
isso pode ser a melhor de todas as fitas
cada peça teria que estar gritando
resolve
você está viva você pode tudo
eu acreditei e acreditaram em mim sabem
no que deu
foi o resíduo siga fui
ai gente venceu e elton ricardinho joel
silver shine on you baby
e tem mais
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no dia seguinte ao disse lhe eu consegui
sentir na pele que aquilo estava
funcionando
levei meu filho a conhecer a fábrica
chão de fábrica uma 600 pessoas
todos os que os trabalhadores que
produzem os as meninas das máquinas do
overlock os cortadores
e à medida que eu ia passando pelo
corredor
essas pessoas essas queridas pessoas que
fazem a fábrica elas começaram a bater
palma
elas começaram a fazer o sinal eu te amo
naquele momento eu estava ouvindo e
tinha certeza que elas muitas delas
estavam dizendo se a dona helena com
quase 80 pode eu também posso
a criança eu quero muito que vocês
conheçam um grande amigo meu mas tem sim
ele me inspira
ele tem uma frase lindíssima kids
criatividade é mais importante que o
conhecimento gente todas nós temos um
pouco de conhecimento
todos nós temos um pouco de criatividade
até eu nem sabia que tinha tanta muito
muito muito obrigada
uma avó
[Aplausos]